[Music]
we're all cleaned up cars packed we're
ready to go to Scotland all right guys
you ready to go to Scotland we swung by
the Stanton edge which is famous because
it was featured in the new Pride and
Prejudice the view is touching me I
gotta be a little careful driving all
three boys are asleep and when I make a
shark turd you didn't hear heads
smacking against criminals alright guys
welcome to Scotland
[Music]
well seven hours in the card we're here
a little southeast of Edinboro in
Scotland and we're go take out our new
rental property big old TV in the
kitchen is a kitchen living room hot
little eating area alright this will do
very nicely oh yes biggest fridge we've
seen the whole trip that's that's nice
and the washer dryers in the kitchen
right next to the oven check it out the
kitchens like the underside of a
souped-up Honda Civic we're outside that
we don't have kids
by hand we're officially on it for our
apartment is just one block away from
the ocean here we're in Musselburgh
which is southeast of Edinboro a little
tidal harbor right here and nice little
beach so you know the kids are gonna
come play down here at some point like
hundreds of years old yeah it's
basically a Scottish strip ball but it
kind of looks fancy and historic doesn't
it
there's a nice view isn't it
[Music]
that was fun well good morning and
welcome to our first day in Scotland and
I am making breakfast and I have one of
the most amazing things in my hand this
is bacon lardons cubed chunks of bacon
steak there we go well today we're going
to explore Edinboro and we're a little
slow getting out the door all of us are
tired this is a razor clamp a bit of old
pottery
all right guys let's go show mommy our
treasures hey guys okay outside outside
oh all right we're finally in the car
and off to Edinboro the girls here to go
see museums and me and the boys or
you'll see about getting some kilts
there's Duke of Wellington not to be
confused with Duke Ellington's alright
we're here at the Georgian house and the
girls are gonna take Jacob and explore
the museum Melanie is super jazzed for
this
[Music]
[Music]
we had a lovely time thank you
visiting the Georgian house was
interesting when you doing a Scottish
jig there Elliot a Harry Potter store we
should get diggable Ark Ness monster
that's a pretty cool Loch Ness monster
[Music]
alright guys I'll get myself a tweed
jacket a real a real tweed jacket is
that cool each one of these patterns
these patterns is for a different family
now you guys through your mom's sides
you're related to the irvine clan
that's the irvine crest right there show
me your kills you like those you're
hopping here will it change in the car
okay all right guys look at me neat hey
Tom
oh yeah there's this of good-looking
boys should we go get mom all right go
get mom hop in and go get buckled in you
look at the Loch Ness monster there we
go hufflepuff eating bread Melanie I
went everywhere every other shop at
Edinboro sells Tartans but almost none
of them sell kids one finally found one
that sells kids sizes forget Irvin
Tartans I mean I just
they had like three colors that was it
looking good boys
one looks like we're all packed up ready
to go let's get the kids in the car
we're gonna head to church and
afterwards we're gonna head out to the
Highlands of Scotland Edinburgh was an
awesome place let's see if we can find
the room to pack a baby well we had a
good time at church the boys looked
redonkulous silly cute and now we're
gonna go four and a half hours northwest
- I saw a cockle cockle in the article
in the Argyle region of Scotland and
we're gonna go check into a little
cottage out in the highlands
[Music]
Oh Dave negligence man farts I'm
disgusted and proud of you son
welcome to the highlands of Scotland ah
kilts are awesome aren't they
[Music]
[Music]
guys the view here is absolutely amazing
may I get back in the car
[Music]
I'm late late that does decide to heart
Cardoso gurgle gurgle
[Music]
[Music]
I hope this is the right house if we
have the wrong cottage we're just gonna
walk into someone's house so we're gonna
go and knock really good first okay here
we go not lovely lovely room
hopefully we're in the right house I'm
like 80% sure now likes it maybe 75
really is gorgeous and they have a
washer and dryer whoo
I sure hope it's our rental this is a
pretty nice place all right let's get
the car unloaded and I'm gonna make some
dinner well we had a nice hearty dinner
and we've got to get the kids bed early
because tomorrow we're going to a
survival school yeah me Tom and Nate are
going out to the woods here in the
Highlands of Scotland to do survival
training good morning and tonight we're
doing the survival school better eat
well guys we're gonna need those
calories it's gonna be really rough out
there we got to survive like wolf
attacks and bears and walruses
absolutely gorgeous it's like rains on
and off like the weather changes every
five miles
it's it's beautiful
it's really beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
let the castle
[Music]
well we got about an hour and a half
until the ferry comes so we're just
gonna be first in line and go explore
the town we have a fossil trilobite and
a shark tooth see I don't know what do
you think about that is that cool it is
I'm gonna hold onto this for you and
when you get a little older then you get
to have it hey Thomas chicken take this
out of this old carpenter Jules
look at that that's an eel spear these
spoons are made out of horn yeah
all right we got lunch this barely mean
I probably curry our ticket curry he's
taking bottles life is good
[Music]
welcome to our number two most westerly
part
[Music]
thank you thank you as pastor the guy
got my left tire in the muck a little
bit on the shoulder and so we tried to
push out and the car just slid properly
into the ditch but luckily people are
very nice and a guy with a tow strap
came along and we got ourselves free
well it's only a couple hours before we
start our survival camping trip and
we're gonna go check out the castle tear
I'm here it's on lock Moy dart that is
hardcore fishing yeah that's that guy
serious man you know I got these castle
ruins right there and it's on a little
pencil and and you got to wait till low
tide to get to it come on you imagine
being a soldier and trying to attack
this castle isn't this pretty look at
all these flowers that is cool inside
well this is as far as I go
nobody attacking from this side well the
weather's better on this side of the
castle accidentally you accidentally
kicked the rat while you're walking yeah
well that was fun this is really awesome
I glad we did it but I am wet and I got
a little sneak peek of how my evening is
gonna go we have 40 minutes until we've
got to leave for our survival camping
trip so hopefully we can dry our clothes
in 40 minutes
[Applause]
alright boys
hop on out them all off first and wheel
you see these noseeums are everywhere
they are gnats or whatever so the boys
have got themselves hoods and I might
bust one out here to it a little bit but
so far I'm doing ok miss Nathan what is
that a star to file this class we're
doing is through wild wood bushcraft
calm and Leon here's gonna be a our
teacher hissed this man has bitten off
more than he can chew he is gonna see if
he can survive a four-year-old in the
six year old do you think we should
build it right here this looks like a
pretty awesome spot man this tree is
cool knock on wood we'll have a pretty
good good night's rest in that so we got
this other shelter here made up for the
boys you see it's not a little bit more
space in there you can see what it looks
like inside you know pretty nice plenty
of room for two boys all right we got
the shelters built now we're gonna go
and try to get a fire going cook a
little food before we put the boys to
bed all right guys you snuggled in good
are you warm are you dry good
alright alright welcome to home sweet
home let me show you the master bedroom
yep that's it we're just gonna kind of
suck it up and I'll see you guys in the
morning
well good morning it's 6 a.m. and didn't
sleep half bad look at this guy's
isn't this amazing this is what I'm
waking up to a little fire started now
we're gonna try to make some breakfast
here I heard something about seaweed and
flatbread so this is gonna be
interesting if I was actually made by me
to get some practice but I got to cobble
on fire
cool stuff buddy this little thing is a
limpet we're gonna catch a neat one
there we go a little bit of roll a bit
crunchier notice i'm
well it is appalling
[Applause]
there we go time to cook up our haggis
here because we are in Scotland and so
you got to have campfire haggis yeah
they're just made with like sheep lungs
and sheep hearts and sheep stomachs we
finished our haggis and pollux lunch and
we're gonna go explore a little cove
down the way and we're to cut through
the woods and do a little foraging and
along the way just uh just do a little
exploring cool skull cap gold cap
sleeping oh there you go
guys would you like to see little tidal
pools with fish and stuff in it and
crabs well guys we had an absolute blast
on this camping trip we got to see a
part of Scotland we normally would never
see if you want to try this out check
out wild wood bushcraft calm I'll put a
link in the description and Liam can
hook you up here well guys we taught you
how to survive on your own see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
red deer right there
alright guys let's go home to mommy boy
it feels good to get home and clean but
the boys are so covered in bug bites the
midges eighth of a live so you got a
little tick right there I can take it
off you want to take it off
unfortunately they got Lyme disease over
here just like they do in Virginia so
that'll watch the bite mark make sure it
doesn't turn into a rash hi this is Luke
and Jake with the outdoor boys I'm Kim
and we're just being oh yeah well it
turns out that Tommy had seven ticks on
him many in his hair and Nathan had
three so I'm getting rechecked we are
going on a date there's survival and
then there's living
[Music]
[Music]
well Becca that was delicious was it and
it tasted even better with opportunity I
love it dearly but we've had a great
time and we're gonna be going up to Fort
Augustus and Loch Ness tomorrow but it's
been a wonderful wonderful day guys it's
another lovely day we actually have
sunshine out there on the highlands and
we are packing up checking out of our
rental and heading north we're heading
to Fort Augustus which is on the shore
of Loch Ness and we literally have a
rental cabin on the shore of Loch Ness
and Jacob you ought to go fishing with
Daddy on a boat don't ya go fishing for
desi we're here in Fort Augustus now
we're going on a fishing charter and
lock this here in a couple hours we got
some time to kill
check out how dark that water is it's
like ink and it flows right into Loch
Ness which is right over there that's
Loch Ness you saw a baby Nessie right
over there you see fish like you look I
do alright well we got ourselves some
lunch now we're gonna head back go to
the car gets the boys dressed and get on
a boat so Stuart here is our guide he's
gonna be hooking us up we're gonna be
fishing for with trout salmon salmon and
the Loch Ness monster of course of
course no he's not dangerous he's just
he knows that there's food around but if
you want to give this one a little bread
it's a beautiful lake are you excited to
go fishing I love doing these trips but
it's rare I get begging to go on with me
so we're just trouble long waiting for
our first hit keep a steady course there
Jacob keep a steady course it take are
you having fun we didn't catch anything
but man we've had fun so we didn't see
nasty but I think I think we came close
check out Stuart and fish Loch Ness I'll
put a link in the description to his
information and trikey I asked in some
of these big trout and salmon ok well
let's go get checked into the cottage
they go find some food shall we little
sitting area here little fireplace look
at this right on the shores of the Loch
I think I can fish right on that shore
so I might do that we'll see nice little
room here at the view oh we got two
bathrooms that's your bedroom maybe a
little picnic fire pit area down there
by the water this is nice babe well I
don't know how we pulled off this
miracle but me and Becca are going out
to get food two nights in a row without
the kids it's like we're just newlyweds
again
let's grab some dinner and maybe linger
longer than the only anticipated
hello cheeseburgers nachos macaroni and
cheese we would fall americano today
alright guys so the fishing charter
didn't go as planned but I literally am
sitting here in a house on the banks of
Loch Ness it ain't over till I say it's
over
I caught the Loch Ness monster
my first Loch Ness fish a Scottish eel
good morning and welcome to our last day
in Scotland it's been wonderful it's
been beautiful it's been a little rainy
but we've had a great time I've out here
fishing just a little bit this morning I
only had my rods in for like 30 minutes
but I think it's time to start packing
up checking out and getting on the road
well guys enjoy Scotland
ya know unfortunately we have to leave
we're gonna drive south about seven
hours to the city of York and we'll just
see what happens I'm not sure go to York
in preparation for our seven-hour road
trip Becka hit the convenience store
got me some Kinder Bueno ice cream bars
which are absolutely amazing Mr Kipling
fantastic mr. Fox Apple mini bats which
sounds fun and show them the chips smoky
bacon flavor this country is amazing
eight Tommy you need do you guys want to
go to a big castle that has rooms full
of weapons
yeah you do oh I didn't film the castle
[Music]
all right we're here at Inverrary castle
it's the home of the Campbell clan so
yeah the duke of argyll and so if you
are a Campbell your clan seat is here
that's a pretty impressive castle
[Music]
well that was pretty cool but we got to
make tracks because we got a long drive
all the way back to York
alright guys here we are in the
apartment in York four stories serious
yeah for starters the stairs
good morning and welcome to our last
full day here in the UK we're in the
city of York before we go outside scene
we're gonna do a little side video I
have collected every type of peanut
butter and chocolate spread I can find
here in the UK and there are many and
we're gonna taste test each one of them
so I'll try to put a link in the
description when I get that video done
there we go we taste tested them all and
look at this mess it was that fun the
[Music]
Marmite was traumatic
let's go sight see you're I'm excited so
the city of York apparently has a wall
around and there's the old city is
inside the wall and there's this place
called the shambles which is all this
tightly packed group of old buildings
and shops and stuff and that is where we
are headed
alright you ready to go diggin okay
there are an exorbitant number of Harry
Potter stores here the world of wizards
the boy wizards and the shop that must
not be named they've got little wood
Viking swords oh yeah I wrote it on a
llama once didn't work out well
sarsaparilla top-top rhubarb and custard
is called a fizzy wizzy Oh
hey old tombstones are using his pavers
yeah that's woolly mammoth ivory
fossilized fish spinosaurus teeth that
wants too big for you
[Music]
did we go me put on you mom and Melanie
could go check out that Cathedral over
there York Minster and me and the boys
are gonna go look at toy stores look at
this
it's trick sick it looks like fake puke
it's poop
we're number twos are number one
[Music]
hey guys York Minster Abby
one of the few Abbie's has survived
World War two and King Henry VIII I'm in
a Viking store and I've got a mug for my
office manager like you it is a lovely
day and we are going to go check out
fountains abbey which is not to be
mistaken for Downton Abbey which is
completely unrelated
[Music]
this is a Catholic Abbey that was
destroyed by King Henry the eighth when
he decided he wanted to do his own thing
religiously speaking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you only told me we're going to the
ruins of some Abbey am I gonna see a
pile of rocks but this is actually
really cool
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these playgrounds overseas are so much
better than the ones in the US this
stuff would never fly in the u.s. that
was loads of fun I had a lot more fun
there than I expected
we've had a wonderful time but we've got
to get the bags packed and get some food
for the kids get him to bed early cuz
we've got an early day tomorrow got
about a five and a half hour drive to
London and then a seven-hour flight back
to the u.s. we have had such a good time
well good morning guys at 6:30 in the
morning and we're headed to London this
has been an amazing trip
[Music]
well it's 10 p.m. here in Virginia and
the boys did wonderfully on the plane I
hope you guys enjoyed this video because
we had a ball if you want to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe and check out our playlist
with all of our travel adventures thanks
for watching have a great day
[Music]
[Applause]